Good experience.
I guess this is a good time to bring it
up as any.
Um,
you know,
obviously Anthony Bordain took his life
last week and um,
he was a friend of mine and it was real.
That was real hard.
Friday was real hard.
I woke up and um,
I got a text from my friend Maynard from
tool.
Um,
maynard said so much for the Keenan
verses Bordain Celebrity Jujitsu match.
And he was like,
fuck.
And I was like,
oh no,
what does that mean?
And so then I googled it and I saw it.
I was like,
Oh shit man,
I can't fuck what.
Yeah,
just hung himself.
Like,
what?
Yeah,
I don't know.
Were you,
did you know his demons?
Was friends with them,
hung out with him,
got fucked up with them.
Did you get a feeling that he had that
in him?
I didn't know that,
but it was really weird.
It was like he'd been saying really
recently that he'd never been happier.
He was talking about his girlfriend and
saying that it never been happier.
Didn't know it could be that happy.
Didn't know someone could make them that
happen.
Oh Man,
I'm so terrible.
Well,
who knows?
They might have.
They might have broken up.
Who knows?
I mean,
who knows?
I don't know.
I don't.
I mean sometimes people when they say,
I've never been that happy,
you're catching them on these ups and
downs,
you know,
some,
some people,
you know,
people get manic,
right?
I don't know if he was,
but some people get,
they get up and down.
I'll tell you what,
he,
he liked to get fucked up.
Yeah.
Like he liked to drink.
You know,
and he enjoyed it.
It was,
it was something that he enjoyed.
But we,
um,
we did an episode of this show.
We went hunting for pheasants in
Montana.
We cooked over this campfire.
He cooked fantastic.
And really,
and then afterwards we drank whiskey and
smoke weed and he goes deep.
He goes deep.
Really?
Where I'm sitting down,
I'm like,
I'm going to just try to catch myself
real at the world spinning,
deep breath,
deep breath.
He's like,
where's the fucking weed?
They just kept going.
Just kept going.
But I knew he drank,
I didn't know he smoked weed.
Yeah.
He,
um,
he had a heroin problem.
Yeah.
When he was younger and he kicked it.
But he didn't feel the need to just be
sober.
Yeah.
That was kind of interesting about them.
That's a,
that's a thing you bright would get
sober from a drug.
They feel like they have to get sober
from everything.
Yeah.
That did not feel like that.
And he,
by the way,
like he would drink,
but when he was home,
like with his kid and he's homeless,
he didn't drink at all.
Like he would only know that he would
only do that when he would do beyond the
road.
Right.
So He'd want me to show stretches of
time and he didn't drink at all and he
was addicted to Jujitsu.
It was like,
Oh really?
Yeah,
he was doing Jujitsu,
like literally every day when I was
hanging around with him,
he was,
he went,
we were in Montana.
He went to Bozeman to find a local
Jujitsu club and trained with them in
the morning.
She just trained with everybody.
I never,
I hardly ever did that on the road,
find a place I would just go to the gym
and workout wouldn't,
but he was so into learning and getting
better at Jujitsu.
I feel like there's a fundamental
problem with the way people approach
ideas and uh,
I think it goes back to what we were
talking about earlier about right versus
left or Republican versus Democrat.
They're not thinking of the consequences
of arguing for or against the
possibility that climate change is a
human caused thing.
They're not thinking of the
consequences.
They just want to win.
Right,
right.
And what their side to be ready to be.
Right.
And you know,
what bums me out is they don't
understand the consequences of that for
the both the American enterprise and the
human enterprise.
Right.
I mean because you know,
if you,
if you keep calling one branch of
science,
a hoax,
then what's to say the other branches
like,
well,
you know,
then you just,
you're,
you're rolling down this slippery slope
where like the other countries,
you know,
like.
So most of the,
of the Nobel Prizes Americans have one
where people from other countries,
they came here to do their science
because we had the best scientific
enterprise.
The next generation just go somewhere
else,
they'll go to China,
you know,
so,
um,
there's that part of it and the other
parties like,
dude,
it's just science.
It doesn't care about your political
views and you know,
it's not fair to use the cell phone and
take the antibiotics and then turn
around and like,
and then suddenly treat this thing as if
it was another thing in your bucket of
ideologies.
I think also people think that if you
somehow or another compromise industry's
ability to,
to work,
that you're going to kill jobs and
you're gonna damage the economy and
that's more important.
Yeah.
But I think it's the exact opposite.
Right?
And if people really saw,
right,
I mean,
um,
you know,
again,
just like I'm saying,
climate change shows how powerful people
become and also shows how powerful are
our enterprise.
Right?
We did this by building businesses,
by building enterprise bi,
and we built this world curdling machine
of civilization.
And it,
you know,
it,
the planet actually noticed,
why do you like that term world girdling
because that's,
it gives me the girdle wrapping around.
I think it's because it's from like a
Shakespeare,
like from a Caesar or something.
There's a lot of guys you could take out
there that are,
um,
track and field guys or football players
and you could get them to fight better
than him and a couple of weeks right?
Easily because they're athletes,
they're athletes.
They would understand how to shift their
weight,
throw a punch.
And
yeah,
the,
the sparring videos that I saw was,
I think it was from his first fight,
but even then,
like he wasn't,
he signed for like two years before he
had his first fight or something that
there's no way that you're six years
deep in the game.
And yet
he was still at that bad,
you know what I mean?
He doesn't have any talent.
It's all,
it is.
He just doesn't have physical talent or
whatever for whatever reason.
Whether it's a,
he,
his approach,
his intensity,
whether it's,
it's not as coaching.
So at Duke fucking Rufus,
you know,
I mean,
how's the,
with cushman that he talks about Duke
Roufus and one of the put pre fights,
he said,
uh,
how do you see this fight?
It's like,
oh,
I really like a head kick.
Duke would love to see a head kick and
like,
I don't think that's going to happen.
Oh,
that's so crazy that.
So that's such a crazy thing to say,
you know,
Duke's a beautiful person.
He's a great guy in every,
every sense of the word.
He just says he's a great guy.
He did his best.
You know,
there's only so much you could do.
I know.
I mean,
I'm sure you would love working with
Duke.
I'm sure he would love working with you
if you and duke work together.
I'm sure you guys would have a great old
time because you're Joe fucking
chillings right?
And he's Duke fucking relevance,
you know,
let them know.
But,
you know what I mean?
I mean,
you have to have something to work with.
You know,
I mean if duke just grabbed some dude
from a gas station that has been,
uh,
drinking beer and smoking cigarettes his
whole life and had him in a fight in six
months,
how much can you possibly expect?
But I would rather see that fight
against these other ones.
Right?
Let's find out how that would go.
Well,
a guy,
you can find it.
A gas station,
beer and cigarettes.
What's interesting is they both,
both guys fought micky gall first.
It was weird.
Did you see his instagram?
Mickey's?
Yeah,
he did like his own pre-fight,
uh,
with the analysis of how it was going to
go.
It was really good.
Yeah.
Well,
for the little bit that these articles
get right about him,
it's that he's helping men.
He is also helping women,
but yes,
he is helping men.
Men need their shit together.
Need Framework for sure.
I mean,
people need this,
this thing about discipline and you
know,
you are,
you.
Are you aware of,
you know,
you're aware of Jocko willink.
Discipline equals freedom.
It's like one of the best catchphrases.
It's so accurate.
Empowering.
It's so empowering.
Get your shit together and then you the
time that you have for recreation,
you'll appreciate it so much more.
You don't appreciate rest when you're
fucking off all day.
You're appreciate.
Rest when you've worked hard,
that's when it means something to you.
When you've accomplished goals,
that's when this celebration is
something that you get a good feeling
from it.
Do you have a part in your life that you
feel like is lacking in that department?
In what department and just like getting
your shit together,
like not slacking on that.
Yeah,
that's what I do.
I mean,
I do a lot of shit.
They're the only way I could ever do as
many different things as I do is if I
just get after it.
Yeah.
I get after it pretty fucking good.
Yeah,
and I'm not.
I'm not insecure in that.
I mean whether it's through martial arts
or any kind of exercise or work,
I just take pride in getting things
done.
I take pride in working,
you know,
especially working towards things that
are important to me.
Whether it's working on set,
working on my standup,
whether it's working on a podcast,
whether it's working on my martial arts
or fitness or yoga or whatever I get
after it.
Man,
did you got to?
Yeah,
and for me it's not a matter of whether
or not it's an option.
It's like brushing my teeth.
I don't decide one day,
oh,
I don't want to brush my teeth today.
I just fucking brushed my teeth.
And when there's days where I'm doing
fasted cardio,
when that alarm goes off,
it's not a matter of whether or not a
shut the alarm off.
That's not an option.
You Get up,
you put your fucking shoes on,
you get the dog and you go running
because that's what you do and if you
just decide that's what you do,
then you get things done and then a
month later you're like,
oh shit,
we did this all month,
and then six months later it's like,
oh,
I did this half a year.
And then if you're doing Jujitsu,
you like,
Oh shit,
look,
I got a blue belt.
Oh Shit.
Now I'm a purple belt.
And that's how you become a black belt.
Yeah.
You just,
you know,
and I got the good type of progressive
because it gets progressively easier to.
I told you I'm doing that.
It doesn't though,
doesn't get ease,
you know,
think so because can hard every time
that alarm goes off like fuck you for
you now then right when you started,
I don't know because you know the reward
of it,
you know that,
that reward some enforcement.
There's no enforcement in the success
that I've had in completing these tasks.
But every fucking time I go to yoga
class and my God,
Jesus,
Ninety minutes in a 100,
four degree temperature with these all
these women that are going to humiliate
me,
they can definitely do things that you
can do.
Well,
this is tough man.
There's a lot of these older ladies that
are fucking tough.
Yeah.
You know,
they just gutted out.
I was just one lady that goes there.
She's like 60 years old.
She doesn't even bring water and this
lady's in there for 90 fucking minutes.
Sweated out.
She's there.
Every time I go,
I'm like,
Gee,
she's not bringing water.
You sure she's 60.
She can be like 20 and hydrated.
Oh,
she's gray haired and tough as shit.
She drinks water before she drinks it
after,
but when she's in that class,
she's just tough.
It's just,
you know,
it's never easy to do.
You know,
it gets a little bit easier when you get
better at it,
but then you just try harder and it
makes it more difficult.
If you're always giving 100 percent
effort,
it's always going to be hard.
You know,
you take some pride in the fact that now
I can go two miles through the hills and
you know,
and reach the point of exhaustion where
before it was one or whatever,
whatever your little little progress
markers are,
you get some satisfaction that.
But it's always difficult to get going.
The hardest step is the first step is
not the 30th staff or the hundredth
step.
It's the fucking first one.
It's getting on the trail.
Getting going.
It's the hardest thing.
The hardest weight to lift is the first
one because once you get going like,
okay,
I'm a half hour into my workout,
I'm writing things down that I'm
supposed to be doing.
Now I got,
you know,
Twenty Chin ups and burpees and then all
you have to do it,
you just have to do it and so many
people have a hard time doing it.